former President Barack Obama blasted
the Trump administration's response to
the pandemic in his endorsement of Joe
Biden's presidential campaign in a
12-minute prepared video mr. Obama urged
Democrats to rally behind his former
vice president he said Biden has the
character and experience to guide us
through one of our darkest times at
O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 and
Democrats have waited a long time to
hear from the former president
they sure have Anthony and after staying
mostly out of campaign politics for the
past three years it's clear he had a lot
to get off his chest while he didn't
name President Trump
directly the former president accused
him and congressional Republicans of
denying the science of pandemics he also
accused them of trying to kick millions
of people off their health care during a
public health crisis because one thing
everybody has learned by now is that the
Republicans occupying the White House
and running the US Senate are not
interested in progress they're
interested in power so our country's
future hangs on this election and it
won't be easy the other side has a
massive war chest
the other side has a propaganda network
with little regard for the truth mr.
Obama praised Biden's platform is the
most progressive of any major Party
nominee and cited his past work on
dealing with the epidemics like h1n1 and
Ebola and the 2008 economic crisis as
reasons why he's ready to be President
mr. Obama also praised senator Bernie
Sanders isn't and his outreach to young
voters he sent fundraising emails and
texts for Biden yesterday and says he'll
be back out on the campaign trail as
soon as he can
Tony so will we as soon as we can yeah
we're all looking for that for that
moment if it comes we'll be there all
right thank you very much